I'm Ron Vale I'm a professor at the
University of California San Francisco
for my research I've been interested in
molecular motors and the cytoskeleton
for many years although I would say I'm
just generally fascinated with
biochemistry and cell biology and the
lab now also works on other topics
involving t-cells and RNA as well in
addition to science very interested in
scientific communication I founded I
biology set up programs for young
scientists in India and I'm also
involved in efforts to try to make
science communication more open and
available throughout the world I didn't
come from a scientific family my parents
were from the movie industry in
Hollywood but my mom took me to museums
when I was very young and I loved the
dinosaurs I loved looking at the stars
at the planetarium
I was just captivated by all Wonders
that you know were presented at these
museums I suppose I got interested in
biology specifically when I was in high
school and I had to do you know your
standard high school science fair like
project but I really got into it and I
picked a topic which was circadian
rhythms and I turned our basement into a
laboratory where I could measure
circadian rhythms of bean plants and how
their leaves would move up and down
during the day and night that was my
first exposure to not just learning
science facts but trying to develop a
question that I was curious about and
wanted to answer after doing that I just
said I I want to make discoveries I want
to answer scientific questions
you